je vais rester dans votre voiture donc
mûri bâti manette vous êtes passagère 5
étoiles selon mes critères
on va boire un verre on restera une
heure ou deux je ne serai avec mes frais
c'est quoi ton numéro p 6 moi je sais
pas trop je veux aller là tu te viens me
faire plaquer décidé de la prendre
y'a pas moyen qu'elle ferme sa grande
gueule et cotonou je dois être quelque
part dans une heure environ avant toi
j'ai déposé une fille demande lui sied
de nous accompagner à une soirée de
tincques un marivaux s'il accepte je
serai tout chauffeur donc où est ce que
tu dis que cette fête a lieu déjà
tu étais une cliente et maintenant on
est tous amis c'est vraiment adorable
je paye les bouteilles mais je vais
avoir besoin d'un peu de cash sa tempête
d'hier et pour moi là je préfère être
ailleurs a déjà vu ce qu'un magnum 44 de
fer au visage d'une femme salle fait
littéralement exploser du poids vous
appelez la police but évêque non je peux
savoir que vous jouez par un [ __ ] de
jeu mêlant veilleux j'étais en train de
rater
les taux courts à quoi tu montes tu
voudrais pas rater la panne dont propre
regard